for the first time in decades from the
jordan river to the mediterranean sea
palestinians both in the occupied
territories and those living in israel
are taking part in protests and a
general strike
they are calling it a day of rage
this was bethlehem in the occupied west
bank just a short time ago
where there have been confrontations
between israeli security forces
and palestinian protesters israeli
security forces are using
live ammunition there at least 12
palestinians have been injured
we are also hearing reports of israeli
snipers in the area
similar scenes near ramallah as well
where they've been
armed confrontations between some
protesters
and israeli security forces those are
still
ongoing though they have calmed down a
little bit they've also been tense
scenes in nablus in the occupied west
bank where demonstrators have been
facing off with israeli security forces
one palestinian protester was killed and
more than 160 others
injured during demonstrations across the
west bank
two israeli soldiers have also been
wounded
and earlier this was the scene near
damascus gate
in the occupied east jerusalem
protesters there heeded calls for
demonstrations
but were met with an israeli crackdown a
photojournalist was targeted
and many protesters were beaten
let's go first to al jazeera
correspondent nida ibrahim
she was reporting live to us near
ramallah when those shots
were fired she was talking to my
colleague
to talk more about what brings these
protesters here
we're joined now by a palestinian who
was at the protest
you have been living here you were born
and raised under occupation
what makes you think that this
we're seeing crowds are leaving we're
not sure what's
going on there are people palestinians
who are
who who
we're going to let you get to a place of
safety because it sounds rather
dangerous where you're reporting from
nida ibrahim uh we're going to check in
with you and come back to you later on
let's go to nida ibrahim she's live for
us now nida that was
uh very dramatic uh that footage there
uh taking place live
on air uh talk us through exactly what
happened
and were any people injured as a result
of it
we were here reporting from a hill
overlooking the confrontations here near
the illegal israeli settlement of bethel
when we heard gunshots and people
leaving
we believe that those were palestinian
militants for a shooting
towards the israeli army that is near
the illegal settlement of vettel that
has been already fighting if
firing at the palestinian protesters at
the scene
now later on the confrontations
intensified and the palestinians
have been leaving the scene we're seeing
many many
less numbers than the ones we've been
seeing since the protest started when
the protest started we were talking
about the largest protest that we've
been seeing
since the start of the escalation last
monday
but now more palestinians are returning
to the scene
and we hear every now and then sounds of
shots from the israeli forces and then
we hear the ambulances taking
those wounded to the hospital now as a
result of that exchange of fire we
weren't able to identify how many
palestinians
were shot at by that certain
exchange of fire but all in all
palestinian medical sources talk about
several hundred palestinians who have
been injured
all over the occupied west bank and
competitions going on in different
cities as well
but they say that 60 of three of these
injuries were here
in ramallah were transferred to
hospitals in the city
and that more than half of those were
hit
by live ammunition and anita do we have
a sense
of how things are going to develop now
because the day
started off as you were describing with
many thousands of people
coming out including families with
children
then then the scene turned violent it is
heading towards evening
now where you are do we have an
understanding at all of how
things are going to develop
well this scene of exchange of fire is
something that is not
usual in these protests we see them
every few years potentially
happening in a different military
sorry happening near a military
checkpoint
but it's not the something that we can
say it happens regularly it's hard for
us to predict what's going to happen
once
the sun sets usually when the sun sets
it becomes dark and
the the surroundings here become very
dangerous it's hard to know where
the israeli army is coming from or
whether if
more militants are going to arrive at
the scene it's very unlikely since
the west bank is not known for
its weapons and usually the israeli army
when they
receive information about people who are
carrying arms they go in and harass them
and take them
so it's hard to predict how the day is
going to be
heading when it comes to those firing or
militant palestinians
but when it comes to those protesters i
can tell you that many of them are still
here
they're refusing to go but the numbers
are much less
than the ones we've seen since the
protest started here near the illegal
israeli settlement of vettel
nida ibrahim there for us in ramallah
many thanks
let's take you now to bethlehem in the
occupied west bank our correspondent
harry fawcett is
live there harry many dramatic scenes
where you were earlier today we were
seeing
all kinds of uh tactics being used by
the
israelis uh talk us through uh
what happened where you are
sure well i mean just right now uh a
couple more stones have just
landed sort of near our feet here you
can see
the protesters are really quite a long
way pushed back in the distance but the
pattern has been that
they will gradually approach this
israeli
border police uh or military area
what we also heard just before we came
on air was
a large volley of tear gas to uh
this side of the camera which is uh to
the
to the west where we um know that the
ida refugee camp is so it seems that
a lot of the concentration of the action
has now moved from this street
to that refugee camp uh earlier though
as you say yes this was
the focal point of many uh encounters
and injuries sustained on the
palestinian side between
the palestine protesters and the israeli
military here the what we've seen is
them approaching
throwing stones initially when the
larger
body of the protest headed up this road
there was
an immediate uh dispersal of them
by a very large round of tear gas
and since then it's been these sort of
running skirmishes where people will
approach
throw stones and then the israelis will
do one of a number of things they've
been out
surprising them from hidden areas in
houses nearby
grabbing one of them violently and
taking them away they've been using the
tear gas and skunk water
to drive them away they usually
involving troops coming out and
confronting
in one way or another but in the most
recent
such episode nobody came out from the
the outpost here behind us it was simply
the use of sniper fire
uh we saw one man fall down injured by
that live bullet
and the street was dispersed pretty
quickly as people ran
into the alleyways and further up the
street away we know that there have been
at least
12 injuries here by israeli live
fire another 11 at least
hit by rubber coated steel bullets one
of those at least
a puncture wound from that weaponry
there's also as i say been
skunk water this very toxic
very putrid chemically laced water
being used and stunned grenades and tear
gas
very very heavily so dozens of people
also injured in terms of the effects of
that tear gas
yeah harry i was actually going to ask
you for you to describe
what skunk water is we can't assume that
people watching know what that is
do you get a sense at least from what
you're describing
that quite heavy-handed tactics are
being used there
by the israeli military to uh
to bring that protest to an end
to say the very least it's extremely
heavy-handed i mean we're talking about
stones and rocks and children's marbles
just
a few centimeters in diameter uh
being thrown against uh a wall of
concrete and steel
behind which the israeli troops are
stationed
and in return the amount of firepower
we've seen on display just
in this isolated protest on this
particular
few hours of one afternoon is pretty
extraordinary uh not least of course in
fact
the most uh the most dangerous and
lethal of all of that
is the live fire that we've been seeing
used we've seen snipers
shooting people who have been uh using
uh using slingshots and their own bare
hands to
to throw objects at this very heavily
protected very
heavily armed first world army uh
and so yes it's uh that is the that is
how things
play out here it's how things are
playing out right now
no deaths that we have reported here so
far but there have been
elsewhere uh there was uh as nida was
reporting an exchange of fire further
north further south
the day began with an attempted uh
according to the israelis an attempted
attack at a checkpoint
outside hebron where the israeli army
says they were approached by
a palestinian who was carrying a
homemade gun a knife
and some kind of explosive device uh and
that he was shot
and in their terms neutralized uh that
means he's been killed
okay many thanks for that harry fawcett
there for us in
bethlehem and the occupied west bank as
harry was saying
those protesters moved quite far back
down that street we can't really see
them very clearly but they are still
there
let's take you to southern israel and
our correspondent imran khan
uh is live there for us uh so tell us
exactly why
you are where you are earlier you were
talking about
uh how that particular position
might have brought some hope to the
people in gaza who are suffering
a very tough humanitarian situation
that's absolutely right the reason i'm
here today was there was
some sort of hope particularly from the
aid agencies that karim abu salam
crossing through the gaza barrier into
gaza was going to open
for a humanitarian convoy carrying much
needed aid
to get into gaza the united nations uh
collecting
aid from various different aid agencies
including medicine some frontier
uh the world health organization and
others
drove their trucks early in the morning
down to the crossing it's only a few
kilometers
that way and they were hopeful that they
would be able
to cross then a number of incidents
happened
throughout the day firstly there was
real confusion in the morning
as to whether the israeli army would
allow them to cross
in the very early hours they said no
it's not going to happen we're not going
to let you
cross then they were the israeli army
released another statement saying
actually we're in discussions hopefully
uh all the parties will agree and we'll
we can get the
crossing open i'm paraphrasing there
clearly
however it didn't happen it didn't
happen for a few
hours as we were stood here we saw three
jordanian
army donated mobile field hospitals
absolutely crucial
given what's going on in gaza come in
they didn't even get
to kareem abu salam they're crossing
into gaza they got about
half a mile down the road and then they
turn around and came back
so we saw those trucks return i spoke to
somebody from the un quite a senior
source who told me
nothing is going to get into gaza today
and this was supposed to be the
breakthrough now what happened
throughout the day
and this may well have had an impact is
there was a barrage of rockets
from the gaza strip most of them
intercepted by the so-called iron dome
rocket defense
system but some did fall now in that one
in one of those attacks 10 people
were injured two of those died of those
injuries later they were farm workers
thought so throughout the day we heard
one israeli soldier had been injured in
a fire just about
i don't know two miles down that way he
was brought
to an ambulance here and the ambulance
went uh into israel
now then we heard a mortar attack happen
at kerim abu salam where another israeli
soldier was injured whether that had an
impact on the israelis
in opening that border we don't know but
certainly all of this has made it much
more difficult
for the aid agencies to try and get that
much-needed humanitarian aid
in to the gaza strip now whether it
happens tomorrow or not we are not
sure uh certainly there'll be
conversations going on between
the united nations and the israelis in
hopefully getting that border open
but right now no one's confident that
that sorry not border barrier will be
open
okay imran khan there for us in southern
israel many thanks
for that update
well let's get the latest in gaza the
death toll from israel's bombardment
there keeps
rising and the humanitarian situation is
only getting worse
israeli airstrikes have killed at least
213 palestinians so far
that includes 61 children thousands of
people have been made homeless
and are sheltering in schools israel's
prime minister benjamin netanyahu has
warned the military operation against
hamas in gaza
will continue
our enemies see what price we are
charging for the aggression against us
i am sure they will learn the lesson we
will continue the operation in gaza no
matter how long it takes
we took on hamas years back and the
enemies around us are learning their
lessons of what we can do to them if
they dare to attack us
well we can go live to gaza and speak to
our correspondent al jazeera suffereth
al khaloot
uh safwat you are i believe standing in
front of the
uh ministry of health uh bring us up to
date with the very latest where you
are
well where i am we could hear some
explosions right
just few seconds ago uh the explosion
started from
their israeli artillery who are
stationing
across the israeli gaza borders
a few minutes ago we also heard that one
of the tank shells landed in one of the
houses in shijaya neighborhood which is
the east of gaza city
which uh this this is the first uh
palestinians who dies today which all
which another significant or indication
that
uh the level of fire is reduced
in comparison with yesterday or the days
before
i we heard lots of talks about
ceasefire about intensive talks
related to ceasefire or reaching an
agreement uh
islamic jihad confirmed to us that they
have been receiving
tens of phone calls every day including
today
but in reality or underground there is
no ceasefire
reached or or they said he said that or
they said islamic jihad
that the the mediators are asking or
talking about
either uh mutual ceasefire
or one-sided cease-fire he said we have
only one condition
or the according to him that palestinian
fighting groups
have one condition that israel stopped
all
the practices all the aggression that
they started in jerusalem
then he said we can talk about the
ceasefire and we are ready to seize the
fire immediately
if the israelis apply or agree on this
condition
uh on the on back to the rimal clinic
which is the only source
uh for handling or dealing with covet 19
this building has completely damaged and
to the left here we have the
the lab that have been uh
making the covete 19 test it's also
completely stopped
anyway covet 19 it becomes part of the
of the past as the doctor said because
all the measures all the
preventative measures or the protocol of
covet 19
has completely destroyed since
thousands of palestinians have have been
evacuating their homes
and had to stay in the united nations
schools for sheltering
and on the other hand since also many
other people or hundreds of families
they have also to leave their their uh
their
buildings after they the israelis
destroy them and they
uh they move towards or to for living
with their relatives
of with their friends so the covet 19
according to the doctors here focus or
concentrates
and keeping distance as far as
preventative measure but in these cases
in this war
or escalation the main principles have
been completely damaged and destroyed
so no uh covet 19 protocol is
implemented people without masks
we could see in the schools tens of
people in one room
staying in one room families staying in
one room using all materials
as a urgent
alternative and of course the hospitals
in gaza they have been
receiving lots of injuries which uh
which forced the ministry of health to
uh use the the
special departments that they use for
covet 19 to receive and treat the
injuries
and staff what i i understand that many
of many of the roads much of the
infrastructure has been destroyed
uh people uh can't even actually make
their way
to some of the hospitals is is that your
understanding of the situation that
people can't even get the help that they
need the medical help that they need
because of the roads
well the health system has been
collapsing for a long time and we
uh under the recent escalation he
even made it worse so uh before the
escalation the people who used to go to
the hospital
they used to buy the medicine from
outside so
whenever anyone uh which is which became
like something usual and
well known in gaza that if you go to the
hospital they give you the
the prescription and you buy the
medicine from outside
because of the serious shortages of of
the medical supplies in gaza hospitals
on the other hand the infrastructure
either electricity
either water either the main roads have
been
some of them completely destroyed and
some are
partially damaged it's difficult to
reach hospitals
not because only the roads are damaged
but because of the fear of moving from a
place to another
and sometimes you have quite the
situation is quiet
and suddenly you have tens of airstrikes
bombing all over the gaza strip
so there is fear there is shortages in
the in the hospitals
and of course the reaching the hospitals
is something also difficult uh because
either uh the road are destroyed and
also the ambulances
spend most of the time uh patrolling
and rushing towards the destroyed or the
bombardier areas to carry
injuries or casualties from the
destroyed places
i also i've also been hearing that there
is a real
uh urgency when it comes to lack of
water and sanitation is now also a
problem
uh because many of the pipes have been
destroyed and that there's sewage now
going onto the streets so you talk about
the threat of covid and the injuries
people are facing but once you don't
even have the basics like sanitation
that can only breed things like disease
i mean the situation is really dire
isn't it
uh i spoke to the mayor of gaza and had
long chat about what they can do and
what are
what is guys expecting he said that
gaza the municipality of gaza is running
out of fuel and
they don't have the necessary equipments
for
dealing the solid waste he said they
have only few days and few
uh hundreds or thousands of liters for
using
a fuel for using or for moving their
their heavy duty machines that they use
for carrying
and cleaning up the streets the sewage
is also another
essential problem here important problem
since the the network the sewage network
has in many places it has been destroyed
and in some other places has also
damaged he told me that they have no
choice but
to uh to push or to pump the raw sewage
into the sea which will cause
environmental
problems or environmental pollution so
from one hand
they are not they don't have enough uh
capability or enough
abilities enough machines enough fuel to
continue
uh introducing the sanitation services
collecting the garbage and even dropping
it because the garbage
that they collect they have uh a place
that
are like a certain place near the
borders where they push or
drop all these solid waste near so which
is now
quite difficult to reach or that needs a
very special coordination with the
israeli army
through the international organization
so yes gaza
is from the uh from the health
perspective from the
infection he said that they are
expecting
environmental uh problem they have they
are expecting that these
solid waste that they will not be able
to gather and drop
near the borders that will cause lots of
diseases
okay many thanks for that safwat al
khaled al jazeera's correspondent there
in gaza let's get a bit more on
efforts being made outside of the region
to bring about an end to this conflict
we've heard recently from the european
union of foreign ministers they've held
an emergency video meeting on the
situation in israel and palestine
the eu foreign policy chief joseph
burrell is calling for an immediate
ceasefire between
the two sides we
support the right of defense to israel
and the right to security
also for the palestinians and we
consider that security for israel and
palestine
requires a true political solution
because only a true solid political
solution
could bring peace and for doing that
we need to restore a polite political
horizon
now the priority the urgency is to stop
violence
and to implement a ceasefire
let's bring in uh marwan bashara al
jazeera senior political analyst he
joins us live from
doha marwan uh so this call from
european leaders coming after we heard
from president biden yesterday
also calling for a cease fire after
having a conversation
with uh prime minister netanyahu of
israel
do you get a sense uh now that
the pressure is on to bring about
an end to this conflict that something
is going to happen
no i don't actually and i think we
probably should be a bit more
nuanced in the way we see what is
happening from the european
uh the effort is too little too late
too little too late and there's a
there's a great
degree of cynicism in the way european
leaders are calling the israeli prime
ministers and congratulating him on the
efforts
being made as this as they call it in
support of israel's security
when everyone knows what is happening is
israel defending its occupation
not its national security so there has
been a certain degree of complicity
between the european leaders and the
israeli government
as for the american president i think
i think let's uh let's check it i think
what he
did what he did say is that he supports
a ceasefire he did not call or demand
a ceasefire he says he supports one and
who
who does he think will actually demand
one
when he himself and his administration
have vetoed
uh such a ceasefire proposal at the
united nations
so clearly the europeans and the
americans are moving very very slowly
giving prime minister netanyahu and the
israeli right
the time to finish the job and what is
the job
with the job apparently is five one
yes to destroy the infrastructure of
hamas
but more importantly to destroy the
infrastructure
economic financial administrative and
municipal
in gaza three to destroy the livelihood
of so many gazans
so as to force them to turn against the
rulers of gaza
ai hamas and fourth to satisfy the
israeli
radical racist right and fifth
to maintain his own political future and
to stay in power
these are not goals that the european
union should share with israel
these are not goals that the american
administration should share with israel
unfortunately there's a great degree of
cynicism
on part of the europeans and the
american governments
a cynicism that is mating that is
meeting
meeting that is meeting a certain degree
of sadism
on the part of netanyahu and his
government
let me pick you up uh on that point you
made about the united nations uh because
as you said they met
on sunday uh the the united united
nations security council met
uh virtually on sunday and so far the
u.s has blocked at least three attempts
by the u.n security council to release
some sort of
joint statement uh on the situation in
gaza but our understanding is
uh they are uh once again holding
discussions
on the situation in israel and palestine
and uh
we are expecting some sort of uh live
event uh some live statement from them
again
uh what are your thoughts on the unsc
uh do you think they can do anything uh
when it comes to this conflict uh
between palestine
and israel or is it just talking heads
essentially
well certainly they have failed the last
70 years
you know we lost count of how many times
the general assembly has passed
resolutions
about say the right of return how many
times have the u.n security council
passed resolutions about the occupied
territories as uh
uh under the fourth geneva convention
where international humanitarian law
must be applied so many resolutions have
passed at the united nations and
nothing happened israel simply did not
respect them and
the united states protected it and to
some degree the europeans so what we
have now and and this is a bit what
puzzles me
what we have now is this incredible
effort to come up with a statement
so what i mean so they come up with a
statement and then what
why why is a statement so important i
mean it is
important symbolically but how is it
important
functionally how will it be applicable
how will it be enforced who will enforce
it
who will use a certain leverage on the
israelis and
say the palestinians to stop we're back
to square one
so i think although we're talking a lot
about
them agreeing on a statement which
probably will be watered down
so much that probably
the israeli government will be laughing
it out to the
to to gaza and yet you know we say
good let them have a statement why not
but
but i don't think we should build we i
don't think we should depend
on the investment so much while gaza
bleeds
while the war escalates while the
infrastructure the water the electricity
the economic life of our
millions of people are getting destroyed
marwan who actually has the leverage to
actually bring about an
end to the current conflict that we're
seeing in palestine in israel is it just
the united states
well the united states is the one
that has supported israel with over 200
billion dollars if anyone knows anything
about the history of financial aid
well in terms of just dollar figures
this is four times more than the united
states
gave to the europeans in the marshall
plan after the second world war this is
how much the united states gave israel
in terms of
military and financial aid the united
states is israel's patron
it's the defender of israel in the
international arena it's the supporter
of israel
in terms of economics in terms of
technology in terms of armament in terms
of diplomacy
in terms of strategically and every
other way and
israel owes the united states
for all these services rendered for the
protection it provides israel because
without the united states israel would
not be able not only to maintain its
national security
but certainly it won't be able to
maintain its occupation
it wouldn't have been the formidable
force it is today economic
or strategy so certainly the united
states
has the capacity when there's will
there's a way as they say
but clearly there isn't a will on the
part of this administration
like most most other previous
administration to exercise that leverage
against israel when it comes to the
europeans they have important economic
and diplomatic relations with israel
they also have some leverage less than
the americans but they certainly have
some leverage
together the europeans and the americans
could in fact
discipline israel for its own sake for
the sake of
israeli security for the sake of the
security of israelis
they could discipline the netanyahu
government because as i said earlier
two of the most important objectives of
this
horrible war are cynical calculations on
the part of netanyahu and his clique to
stay
in power this is not in the best
interest of the united states or the
european union
and certainly not in the best interest
of of peace and security in the region
what do you think marwan is israel's
game plan here
what do you think it wants the country
to look like 10 or 20 years from now
i tell you one of the things that you
played just earlier a few minutes ago
that clip from netanyahu i find it
probably one of
one of the few very disturbing things
i've heard throughout this conflict when
he said
and i think i'm paraphrasing i'm not
exactly quoting but i'm paraphrasing i
think accurately he said
we are doing what we're doing in gaza
the way we're doing it
so that everyone else in the region will
learn what we will be able to do to them
if they dare do what hamas did what the
palestinians are doing
that's a very very dangerous statement
the arrogance here
really breeds a whole lot of stupidity
how could someone be saying that i am
making
millions of palestinians pay the price
because i want to deter
others in the region the palestinians
are not some kind of a game that he toys
with
their lives and livelihoods and their
loved ones and their economy and so on
and so forth
are not something for him to bargain and
to play with
in order to make some strategic
lesson to some i don't know who
neighbors what iran hezbollah i'm not
sure
but the fact that he says that he is
that he's doing what he's doing in gaza
that he's continuing with the war in
gaza
for the five reasons i just mentioned
earlier
and he says that i that we we need to do
this and we need to continue with this
meaning palestinians need to continue to
pay the price the civilians need to
continue the price
so that others learn the lesson that's a
terrible thing to say especially when we
are talking about
people under occupation we keep
repeating that but that's indispensable
context
because we are not talking about two
separate countries this is not an
interstate conflict
this is a conflict between occupied and
occupied the occupier
owes the occupied are the right to
defend them
the the necessity the responsibility to
defend them
instead they are using f50s and f75s
they're using cannons and and and drones
to bomb them
to do what for what what's the objective
to teach
a lesson
so marwan the way you describe it
uh i mean we've seen the pictures many
people are seeing the pictures
uh live on air why do you feel
that the international community
including the us
don't seem to have that willingness uh
to go beyond uh words why
isn't more being done why aren't uh
sanctions being put on israel
what is the political climate behind
that
look this is a very good question and
unfortunately the answer is uh you know
for me anyway it's not very convincing
but
i think generally speaking global powers
you know let's say the five members of
the u.n security council
they speak you know they talk they talk
the big talk
but they don't really mean it you know
the united states says something
this administration has said a lot about
putting democracy and human rights at
the center of foreign policy marijuana
i'm afraid i'm going to have to
interrupt interrupt you uh because
uh as i mentioned a little earlier we
were expecting to hear from the u.n
security council who have been holding
discussions on
that situation in israel and palestine
and let's have a listen in
and i believe we can see palestine's u.n
ambassador
there giving a press briefing the
inhabitants of
jerusalem in particular in sheikh
jarrah and sirwan were forcibly evicted
from their homes
while the international community
remained deaf and
silent to the outcry of the palestinian
people the arab group
and before that the arab ministers
condemned the
brutal attacks on gaza and the
systematic crimes
against the palestinian we also
condemned the violation of the sanctity
of the religious
holy sites and the evictions
of palestinians from their homes in
east jerusalem in a time when
we are promoting multilateralism
we firmly believe in the crucial role of
the united nation
system in its entirety it cannot
nor should remain silent in the face of
oppression and passively condone
bloodshed so the arab group
in accordance with the decision 8660
of the council of arab minister of
foreign affairs
held on may 11th
engage in a consultation with the
secretary general
the security council and the
president of the general assembly to
explore
all ways to put an end to the escalation
of violence in this regard the
troika of the arab group in the
absence of the secretary general of the
united nation
who was abroad
from new york met the chef the cabinet
of the secretary general
to support the personal engagement of
the
secretary general in the efforts to
de-escalate
the current violence sequence
we welcome the personal commitment of
the secretary general
and his continued action and
ask him to intensify his contacts
with all the world's leaders to put an
end to the
repression that palestinians are facing
the arab group in close consultation
with the arab non-members
or member of the security council
tunisia
met also with the chair of the security
council and
officially requested to hold an urgent
open meeting
of the security council which took place
as you know
on may 16th we also
called upon the security council the
quartet of the middle east and the
secretary general of the united nations
to resolutely commit to end this
situation
and to relaunch the peace process
to find a just and lasting solution
to the conflict that would establish
a sovereign palestinian state with east
jerusalem as its capital
in accordance with the relevant united
nations
resolutions while the security council
continues its deliberation regarding
this
urgent matter we sincerely hope
that it would put aside narrows
agendas and live up to its
responsibility
to protect human lives however
in light of the grave situation
and given the fact that the security
council
was until now not able to react
or to adopt an outcome document
and formulate a consensual position
regarding the repression facing the
palestinian in the occupied territories
the arab group decided to call for
an urgent meeting of the general
assembly
accordingly and in my capacity as
chair of the arab group i jointly
delivered with my brother
abdu mari chair or ambassador of
niger and chair of the oic group
a letter to the president of the general
assembly
calling for a meeting of the general
assembly to discuss
the latest developments in palestine and
the atrocities palestinians
are facing this letter has been
circulated to all members
states informing them of the convening
on thursday 20th may of a meeting
of the general assembly to discuss the
situation
in palestine i cannot fail the
opportunity to express my gratitude to
the president of the general assembly
for his swift reaction and constant
availability the united nation
as a whole must raise its voice
and contribute effectively to the
achievement of a ceasefire
hence the request for a meeting of the
general assembly
which aimed to support the work of the
security council
by garnering all efforts to recover the
stability
beforehand and mobilizing all the actors
to launch a political process without
any delay in this spain member state
have the legitimate right to express
their position
through this universal and democratic
forum
that is the general assembly and thus
contributing to putting an end to this
escalation of violence and atrocities
palestinian people are facing the
resolution
or to the palestinian issues require
addressing the root causes of the
problem occupation
enabling the palestinian people to
exercise their ineligible rights
to have their independent states within
the 1967
borders with el cotsa sharif as capital
is the only acceptable solution and the
unique way
to bring a real and sustainable peace
to the region and i thank you now give
the floor to
my brother riyad to add
some elements good afternoon everyone i
am
happy to see many friends face to face
i want to begin by expressing our
gratitude to
the arab group to the oic group and
yesterday to the nam group
who have joined in calling for
the meeting of the general assembly
which will take place on thursday
my understanding that there will be a
large number of ministers
attending that meeting and
oh and and we appreciate the fact
that there will be a massive solidarity
expressed to the palestinian people as
it was expressed
in the meet the last meeting of the
security council in which
about 10 ministers including the
secretary general
attended that meeting for us
the immediate thing that we need is
a political will to stop this aggression
against our people
this this current aggression by israel
the occupying power against our people
started at the beginning of ramadan
when they exhibited the israeli
occupying authority along with extremist
racist uh terrorist jewish groups
who were chanting uh in front of babyl
ahmood damascus gate
burned the arabs death to the arabs
denying our people
of their religious right to pray during
the holy month of ramadan
in al-aqsa mosque
these confrontations from the occupiers
in the holy sites and the threats
to expel people from their homes in
sheikh jarrah
and salwan accelerated
the the situation and our people
heroically
peacefully in these locations in
occupied
east jerusalem resisted these fascist
activities by the israeli occupying
authorities
that followed about eight or nine days
ago
by massive military aggression against
our people in the gaza strip
in which up to now and one can count
213 palestinians in the gaza strip were
killed
among them 61 children
36 women 16 elders
and about 1500 injured
and you add to that more than 30
palestinians
in jerusalem and the occupied west bank
were killed and about four thousand
injured seven thousand buildings
in the gaza strip either damaged or
destroyed including
a number of high-rise buildings one of
them
also hosting many of your colleagues
journalists these crimes
against our people require from the
international community
a resolve to stop this aggression
against our people
put yourself in the shoe of the
palestinian people if your country is
occupied
if your land is confiscated
if settlements illegally being
constructed
if people living in their homes such as
being you know threatened to be expelled
from their homes
two million are being put in an
open space jail on the gaza strip for 14
years denying them
freedom of access and movement put
yourself in the
shoe of about 2 million palestinians who
are citizens
of the state of israel being treated as
second and third class citizens
for a long period of time and putting
about 1 000 of them during the course of
the last
eight nine days in prison lynching some
of them
as you have witnessed in allude then
what should the palestinian people do
often you hear some saying israel has
the right to defend itself
what rights do we have do we have the
right to resist occupation
do we have the right to protect our
children before they go to sleep
do we have the right to stop the illegal
settlement
activities and annexation do we have the
right
to express our opinion and to
demonstrate peacefully in the street
do we have the right to go to al-aqsa
mosque and to the church of the holy
sepulchre
and exercise our freedom of religion
without
oppression so those who lecture
to us about human rights then look at
what is happening
to the vulnerable palestinian people who
are saying enough is enough 53
years of occupation with this kind of
ruthless
upper tide occupation against our people
and 73
years since the nakba in which our
people who are citizens of the state of
israel
instead of acquiring their national
rights
and living in freedom and dignity there
in their ancestral homeland
look at the israeli media they are
accusing them
for what they are doing to resist this
onslaught against the palestinian people
so enough is
enough and i can tell you although the
immediate responsibility
of the international community is to
bring a ceasefire immediately
the second you know responsibility or
what we want
we want humanitarian assistance from
all those who can to help our people in
the gaza strip
to uh to provide them with protection
about 50 000 of palestinians in the gaza
strip
are now moving into 43 schools of honor
seeking international protection under
the flag of the united nations
those people they need to be fed they
need to have
medical services they need blankets they
need
all the necessary things including water
and what have you
and protection during this time of the
man-made
catastrophe and i was in a meeting
before coming here
in which madame de carlo was
representing the sg
in that meeting i asked her and i asked
the spokesperson
of the sg who left you a few minutes ago
that it is the responsibility of the sg
to issue an emergency call for
humanitarian assistance to the
palestinian people
in the gaza strip immediately he cannot
continue
to uh to delay this process
honorwa is welcoming all those who are
seeking protection
and afraid for their lives and their
children in these schools
but you know they need to be provided
with
assistance including you know
money assistance to hire more
palestinians
to come and help in this undertaking
of taking care of tens of thousands who
are seeking protections
in these schools
uh this is what we are talking about the
security council is shameful act
of not even expressing a unified
position calling for the end of this
aggression the quartet issued a
statement early in the ball game
a simple statement which in spite of the
fact that it did not
reflect what we wanted but we welcomed
they spoke
all countries spokes the arabs
convened an emergency meeting at the
level of ministers
the oic convened a ministerial committee
uh just recently the nam
agreed yesterday to convene an emergency
ministerial meeting meeting for the
palestine
ministerial committee of nam the
europeans issued their position and
their statement everyone is saying
something
and the institution that is responsible
for the maintenance of international
peace and security
met three times in emergency sessions
and and it was not allowed
to utter a position calling for a
ceasefire
and to stop this aggression against the
palestinian people because one country
did not allow the security council to do
so
so we will tell you after this
aggression stops business as usual
cannot be prevailing in our region
to tell us be quiet let's fix the gaza
strip
let us engage in talks and what have you
that will not elevate itself to what is
needed
what is needed as was demonstrated by
the palestinian people in both sides of
the green light and
in every corner of the globe including
in new york in chicago in washington in
sydney in
malaysia in indonesia in the refugee
camps
in jordan in lebanon in syria
everywhere that we cannot continue
to live under this oppressive upper-tied
regime
that what should happen this occupation
has to end
and we need to have the independence of
our state
with east jerusalem as its capital where
we can live
in in with dignity and freedom
and to begin the process also of
addressing
all other issues facing the entire
nation of the palestinian people this is
what i wanted to share with
you at this
time and again you know i thank my
colleagues
representing this massive group of
countries and we are grateful for this
unity
among all these countries that are
outraged
of what is really happening to the
palestinian people
demonstrating their solidarity and doing
everything possible in order to
bring an end to this aggression against
our people